If you were stuck in horrifying financial ruin,
what would you do?
The only way to escape
crippling debt is to risk your life
playing twisted games with brutal punishments.
I'm here to break down the mistakes made.
What You Should Do
and How to beat the DEBT GAMES in Tomodachi Game.
This honest kid is about to find out
that hard work doesn't pay off.
Yuichi here works
tirelessly for a delivery company and other part
time jobs to pay for his school trip.
And he finally makes enough cash
to go on his dream trip.
However, he's going to soon
realized that it was all for nothing.
The next day, the principal announces
that ¥2 million that they all collected
for their school trip has been stolen.
Black haired girl Shiho begs for forgiveness
for losing the money,
telling the class that someone had taken it
from her locker, that night.
Yuichi receives a letter from Shiho telling him
to meet her outside of school as soon as possible.
That's when he arrives at the entrance,
seeing all of his friends
waiting for him to fess up and tell them why
he sent them all the same creepy letter
asking them to meet up with him.
The group realizes that someone else,
not Yuichi sent them all the same letter.
Suddenly the group is attacked and they black out.
They wake up in a clear white room, only to be
greeted by this creepy looking mascot, Manabu.
He tells the group that they've been entered
into a series of games
each game giving them ¥2 million if they win.
However, there's a catch.
One of them has ¥20 million in debt.
That must be paid off.
This glasses guy, Tenji approaches the mascot
and accuses him of illegally kidnaping them.
But Manabu has a trick up his sleeve.
He tells them that someone already paid
for the entry fee of ¥2 million,
the exact same amount
that was stolen for the school trip.
However, he gives them the option to quit
if they want to.
But whoever leaves
has to pay the debt off by themselves.
Okay.
This is clearly one of the most illegal things
I have ever witnessed.
A group of high school
students have just been blackmailed.
Kidnapped and told
that one of them has ¥20 million in debt.
Now, there's a lot of different ways
to handle this situation.
And I say becoming violent
seems like the easiest one.
If I were these students, I would beat the ever
living crap out of Manabu here.
This serves to purposes
one we get revenge on him or whoever he works for
and potentially beating him down hard enough
that he'll confess who the debt belongs to.
However, in reality, that is a terrible idea.
What we really need to do
is to put on our Sherlock
and figure out who has the ¥20 million in debt.
The phrase whoever smelted
delt it. might be a good idea that we can use
to narrow down our list of suspects.
And at the top of my list is black haired girl
and this glasses guy Tenji with his glasses.
Dudes with glasses are always
the mysterious blokes, but this black haired girl
might just be one of those innocent types
that has a mysterious dark side
when shit hits the fan
and we already know the deal with this dude.
This kid's got some glasses guy energy
about him.
And according to past enemies, the dudes with
glasses are usually bona fide perverts.
Am I right? However,
I wouldn't try ganging up on him just yet.
I would use some psychological trickery
and over time make them spit their dirty
little secrets right into our ear holes.
Manabu introduces them to a fake classroom
and gives them name tags
with a number on the other side.
Each one shows them the 4 million debt they owe,
and if they clear the game, they'll be debt free.
However,
they're not allowed to show the amount of debt
or speak to other people during Question Time.
If they do,
the participants will have their fine doubled.
Manabu shows them a demonstration of what happens
when they all give the same correct answer.
They must work together, or else one of them
will be given a massive debt to pay.
The mascot then gives them their first question
Is the tallest mountain in Japan, Mt. FUJI?
Suddenly the coin moves to no
and they fail the first round.
The second question is given, as does one plus one
equal two, and the coin moves to the wrong side
and they fail once again.
The third question is read out by Tenji, who asks,
Is their country called Japan in English?
The students fail a third time to answer
correctly, and Yuichi here begins to grow
paranoid that someone is sabotaging the game
on purpose with only two questions remaining.
They continue to get the questions wrong.
And then the final part of Game one begins.
The shy girl her has given the final question.
She asks the group, Will we always be friends?
But before everybody can put their finger down
on the coin and answer, Yuichi speaks out and
asks a rather naughty question and is penalized
by having his debt increased two fold.
He tells the group that the answer is simple
Just say yes.
The students make up their mind
and answer the final question
by moving the coin on to the correct answer.
The group has successfully cleared
the game and wins
¥2 million, but Yuichi here is trapped
and in even more debt than before.
After the game, Yuichi and the black haired
girl, Shiho, have a conversation
about who the traitor is.
He accuses her of stealing the money,
but she denies having any involvement
with what happened and with this game.
Okay, that was extremely close.
Things could have gone wrong so quick,
and somebody in this group has betrayed us.
It could be one of them or all of them.
The questions were given to test our knowledge.
They were given to us to test our friendship.
Getting into this situation was bad enough, but
purposely trying to sabotage the group's success.
Well, I mean, somebody here is pretty dang evil.
While we might not be able to catch the traitor
this time around, we should be on the lookout
for telltale signs of a liar in the next game.
Now, things such as eye twitches and looking away
when speaking shouldn't be used as 100%
concrete proof that someone is lying.
These aren't the facts, and there's going to be
a strong punishment for whoever the traitor is.
So we better get it right the first time.
The only way to properly determine
if something is a lie is through inconsistency.
The two most suspicious people are Shiho and Shibe,
both of them announced that the classes’ money was missing.
However, that isn't a sure
fire way to narrow down our list of suspects.
It is a start, though.
If I was Yuichi, I'd be recalling every single
interaction I've ever had with my classmates
from the very start of our Friendship
two before the game started.
We should be looking out for any moments
where our friends
might have backstabbed us
or done something suspicious.
It might sound like a stretch right now,
but with this
we should be able to clue in
to a potential suspect
as long as we're sure of whatever past memory
we can conjure up.
The students are sent to a roof for the next game.
Professor Manabu now introduces Game
two by the name of Bad Mouth Sugar Roku.
Each participant must go into a booth and write
a bad mouth confession about another participant.
Once the messages have been set, viewers
watching from the sky will rate which confession
is the worst in order from first to last.
The ranked confessions will determine
how many spaces they move
down the ladder from one space to five.
The first to reach the end will suffer a massive
loss, but in doing so will give everyone ¥400,000
and reward anyone left on the board
will be given an extra ¥1 million in debt,
but then they have the option to be able
to go home for a bit and skip the third game.
If no one puts down a confession
and leaves the card blank.
Everyone will move down one space together.
And if they keep repeating the process
of skipping the questions,
they will all be able to clear the game
in one piece with a combined ¥2 million in reward.
But if they make that choice,
then they have to play the third game.
Okay, now that we've experienced the glories
of the first game, we need to prepare
for any kind of weird crap that could happen next.
If we really think about it
and break down the game one,
there seems to be an element of trust
that is recurring throughout now.
There
there's always the possibility that whoever stole
the money is in cahoots with this money
sucking game.
I'd be weighing my options out and assessing
what's easier.
Win the game and move on to a third game
or take an increased amount of debt and be free.
If I was Yuichi, the more tempting option
would be to just take on more debt
and lose the game on purpose.
There's no reason to stick around, and no one can
stop us from leaving this place once and for all.
Winning this game and moving on to the next.
Looks like it involves jumping off of a building.
I don't know about you,
but that does not look like a good time to me.
Other than attacking Manabu,
however, there's only one other option
that doesn't involve playing the game.
We could just take a look around
and see if there's any way
that we can get back down this building,
assuming this building is in fact
actually a building and not just some set
that someone cooked up for our sick, twisted game.
If the building is real, there's
many ways to safely descend down a building,
and it requires more brains than brawn.
The chain link fence is a perfect starting point
to begin the descent.
If this is a real building,
they will only have to climb down
a small bit to get down to the next window.
And from then we could try to force our way in
and make our way down to the ground floor
and get away from this game for good.
The first confessions are given out
and the group manages to work together as a team,
moving only one space.
Suddenly, a message appears above them, stating
that they've been penalized ¥100,000.
They're shocked and Manabu reveals that
a different penalty is attached with each space.
And that's when someone puts down a confession
in the next round.
Let the mind games begin.
Shiho moves down five spaces
while the others stay put and the next round.
Three confessions are given out with the black
haired girl taking the lead once again.
The next round is set
and the confession is given out.
Shy Girl.
Yutori is mortified
and is given 100% of the viewer's vote.
Manabu reminds the group that whoever reaches
the goal first will take on everyone else's debt.
The game continues
and the next confession is read and turns out
glasses guy Tenji is lying about his age.
He admits that the confession is a little harsh
but true, and reveals that only
she should know about it since they were childhood
friends.
The results are decided with Shiho
in first Tenji and second as of round six.
Shiho here is in first place with 18 spaces ahead
trashing the competition.
That's when she hosts Steps on a special space
and is given a dangerous ability.
She can pick anyone in the group
to have all of their secrets exposed,
depending on how bad the secret is.
The percentage of votes will determine
how many steps they take.
She decides to choose Shibe, and the mascot
reveals that his lawyer father has been doing
some nasty things after hours and has been
spending a lot of money to cover it all up.
The votes are then decided and Shibe moves
into second place with 17 spaces.
However, Yuichi here has something up his sleeve.
He puts down a confession into the booth
that states Shibe has killed someone.
They take a special vote, and 99% of the viewers
believe that Shibe is a killer.
Now, Shibe is at first place with 22 spaces.
Yuichi comforts him
and assures that his buddy isn't a murderer.
He tells the group to stop fighting
among each other because there's only one bad egg.
And this nest.
And he knows exactly who it is.
However, he's not ready to reveal who it is
just yet.
Yuichi tells them
that the game is extremely suspicious and unfair.
No matter what they do, they'll be penalized
and placed into even further debt.
He reminds the group that round six
was the first time they were given a debt
reduction and realizes
that there are both negative and positive spaces.
The negative spaces were loaded at the front
to make the group lose trust in each other,
while the positive spaces slowly increase in the
second half to reveal that teamwork is essential.
Okay,
now we know that we've been tricked yet again.
However, this is on us.
The game is literally called the friends game.
Everything here happens for a reason
and this is something to keep in mind
if we make it to game three.
Whoever's controlling
this game has stacked the odds against us,
and all we need to do is to think carefully
about our next step.
Now, the hardest part of this game
is to trust our teammates.
The messages flying above us are there for
the sole purpose of making us turn on each other.
If I was Yuichi at this point, I'd let the game
play out as normal without any more planning.
We know that the distrust within
the group is at an all time
high, and there's not much you can do to influence
a bunch of hormonal teenagers.
Let's be honest.
But who knows?
Maybe we can lose the game and ask.
Shibe is evil lawyer father to put a few strings
out and let us off the hook with all of this debt.
Shibe's dad, is pretty sleazy,
but Shibe is our best buddy.
Right?
And that means we could blackmail him
with the information we now have, of course.
It's been broadcasted on live stream,
but we don't know
who the hell is watching this shit
or how many viewers this illegal game even has.
The next round Manabu suddenly announces
that there were ten cards in the box.
Tenji confronts Yuichi and tells them
that his plan was doomed to fail from the start.
Suddenly, he reveals another way
to figure out who the traitor is once and for all.
Since Shiho is going to reach the end regardless.
He tells everyone to write down
the same confession.
I'm the one who applied to the Tomodachi game.
If they all write the same thing,
the traitor will be
the only one who is not going to be penalized.
But everyone but the traitor will be moved
to one space above Shiho, allowing everyone
but the traitor to reach the goal.
The group agrees on this idea
and they all hand in their confession papers.
When the papers are read out,
though, only one reads the phrase.
Yuichi mentioned. Tenji shocked.
He breaks down on the spot and Yuichi demands
that this creepy glasses guy finally reveal
if he was the one who applied for this evil debt
game.
The broken man finally admits that he did it
and the traitor has been uncovered.
But suddenly, out of the blue, Manabu interrupts
to tell them all that Shiho is still going to be
the only one moving on to Game three.
But Yuichi whispers to the mascot
that he lied in round seven and broke the rules.
Suddenly, Manabu announces that the game is over
and Yuichi is penalized by taking Chico's place.
And he's about to leave.
But Tenji gets up and reveals that he also
told a lie and he joins Yuichi in the third game.
The two wake up in a cave
and are told to stay in there for three days.
Yuichi finds a single bottle of water
that is supposed to last them the entire time.
Tenji reveals something shocking.
This is his second time in the Tomodachi game.
This kid is ¥20 million in debt
and shiho is the reason for all of it.
Okay. What did I say about creepy glasses?
Got energy, but false crazy revelations aside,
this situation is really, really, really bad.
And we could die before this third game
even begins.
The average person can only survive
without water for a few days.
At most it wouldn't be so bad if it was just food.
As we can survive for way longer without food.
But water.
Water is something we must have regularly.
And we've been without water for at least a day.
With the kidnaping and two previous games,
this situation is life and death.
However, it's really not that bad
if we do a few simple key things.
What I would do if I was them would be to take off
all of my clothes. Hear me out.
Now I know it might be a bit awkward for the first
few hours, but any extra layers of clothing
will make us sweat more and cause us to lose
precious resources within our body.
This also goes hand in hand with doing
absolutely no physical activity.
There's not much we can do inside a cave
So making sure we don't move around too much
or accidentally argue among ourselves
is the most important thing to our survival.
Once that's settled,
we can focus on conserving the resources
we do have in order to stay alive and sorta
healthy.
We've been given
a single bottle of water between the two of us,
which is not ideal for staying hydrated.
The human body needs at least one and a half
liters of water to stay properly hydrated.
Assuming this bottle is one
and a half leaders, from the way it looks,
we have about 750 milliliters for each of us.
It's not going to be pretty,
but we can survive if we can serve our water
and to limit our physical activity.
After three brutal
days, the boys leave the cave to find themselves
in front of now Sergeant Manabu.
The mascot introduces them to their enemy team
and the final game friendly hide and seek.
Both groups will choose one person
to hide in the forest
and the seekers
will need to find the hidden enemy.
However, the seekers can switch sides
if it looks like they're about to lose.
Suddenly, Manabu tells the smaller group that one
other person and an entirely different team
made it.
Also to game three and if they want,
they can have this person join their team.
Yuichi asks if it's a girl and Manabu says yes,
and Yuichi immediately accepts the offer.
That's when this bombshell of a girl, Maria,
steps out and introduces herself to the others.
Manabu continues with explaining the rules,
telling them that violence is prohibited
against the other team and the hider cannot move.
Once they picked a location.
Surveillance cameras are all over the forest
to make sure they don't break the rules.
They've been given phones that they can use
to contact either side if they want.
And there's a big stash of food
exposed in the middle of the forest
for anyone who's brave enough to go and get it
if they're willing to risk getting caught.
Last but not least, the fighters are handed
a give up grenade if they decide to call it
quits and end the game as the loser.
Okay.
If I were the boys, I'd be using our new teammate
as a complete guinea pig for our operation.
Friendly hide and seek is a game of wits
and using the person who's not starving
is probably the better bet at winning the game.
This is why this slim young Fang
is the perfect bait.
She has no option but to take our advice
if she wants to continue playing anyways.
While it's not going to sound pretty,
we should do our best to convince her
that we're morally sound people
just so we can take advantage of her abilities
when we get the chance by ourselves.
We should ask
Manabu is violence against team mates prohibited?
And if it isn't, that means we can do
whatever we want to this new recruit.
If it were me,
I would have her appointed as the hider
and instantly snatch the give up grenade from her.
We don't know her.
We can't trust her.
And also, this girl, while cute and adorable,
isn't really that innocent as she seems.
No one in the Tomodachi game has made it here
without stepping on a few toes
and breaking a few hearts.
And she doesn't seem any different
with the give up grenade in our possession.
We can tell her to hide wherever we please
and know that the girl couldn't give up
if she wanted to.
Then if we had to estimate that would give us
about three days to find the other hider
before this girl goes crazy or dies
from lack of food and water.
But her sacrifice will be for our gain.
Thank you.
So it's about as far as you can get in anime.
Anyways, Yuichi decides that Tenji is
going to hide in a small cave onto the cliffside,
making sure that the new girl
doesn't know his location.
Three days past, and which he still hasn't
returned to give him food and water that night.
Yuichi tells the opposing team
that he wants to switch sides.
The enemy team
decides to let him in and call their captain
to ask for permission to let him really join them.
He tells them to not let Yuichi join their side.
Instead, he asks the girl to change teams,
but she decides to forget about changing teams,
knowing that he has a plan up his sleeve.
The morning after half of the enemy
team left to give their captain food,
Yuichi has a heart to heart conversation
with a spiky haired blondie here,
trying to make him suspicious of his buddies.
This brown haired kid interrupts to switch places
and Blondie walks over to Maria's bedside
to find out that she's disappeared,
walking deeper into the forest.
He finds the girl
cleaning herself up in her underwear,
and he freaks out and runs back to tell his buddy
what just happened.
But that's when Yuichi steals the food rations
and runs off.
The enemy team chases after them,
and he decides to do something crazy. You eat.
He pushes the new girl off of the cliff side
and she starts to fall to her death.
But Blondie jumps in in the nick of time
to save her from dying.
Yuichi then arrives at the cave and rushes in
to save Tenji from near death.
He explains that he was analyzing the team
for the last few days and pushed Maria off
the cliff
like a madman to use her as a distraction.
The seekers meet back up at the food ration
location where tensions are high as hell.
Yuichi eggs the enemy team
on causing the blind guy to become violent,
but that's when he realizes that he can use
blonde guy's to crush on Maria as a path to victory.
Suddenly, the blond guy requests
to move to Yuichi team and is instantly approved.
That night, the new team member is tied up
and Maria here pretends to fear for his safety.
She tries to find out
more about the enemy captain,
but he reveals that his old captain
didn't even tell them where he was hiding.
Shocked.
Yuichi questions
how he never found out the captain's location,
but then bowl cut hair, calls him and reveals
to Yuichi that he was the captain all along
and tells them that the blond kid is a liability
and resorts to violence easily.
Okay, this might not have been the best idea.
The blond kid is a hot headed individual
and that means we can easily lose this game
by way of disqualification.
However, we can use this to our advantage and
figure out a way to win through the same method.
Using mental mind
games has been the key to our success
throughout all three games,
and this one isn't any different.
If I was Yuichi,
I would tie the kid up as soon as possible,
and luckily the kid is firmly tied to this tree.
I would start by gathering
all the personal information
I can about his ex-teammates
and use that as a weapon.
With this knowledge,
I could leak out juicy details to the enemy team
and try to rile them up enough so that him and his
now opposing team get into a fight.
Because remember, violence
against the opposing team is strictly prohibited
and would instantly disqualify them
if they're stupid enough to get violent.
The next day the enemy team shows up
and tells them to stay put.
Maria tells them that she's going for a toilet
break and runs into Bowl cut Kid.
He confronts her about being planted by the game
masters and demands that she betray Yuichi
by giving her an offer that she cannot refuse.
Moments later, she calls her teammate
to ask about Tenji's hiding spot.
Suddenly, Yuichi spots her revealing
all their information to the enemy team.
The bowl cut kid calls Tenji and tells him
that Yuichi is willing to let his teammate die
if it gives him the win.
She screams out that he's lying and the new
captain reveals that he's right above him.
Manabu orders everyone to meet up
so he can announce the winner.
The winner of the third
and final game is a witch's group.
Everyone is shocked and the fake captain admits
that he pressed the button before the game ended.
Yuichi came up with a genius plan.
He called the fake
captain and threatened to break his buddies
fingers if he didn't give up with that.
The group wins ¥2 million
and the third game is over.
However, they're going to realize
that the Tomodachi game isn't over just yet.
The boys decide to head straight to school
and find Shiho entering the classroom.
They see their old teammate, Yutori,
who tells them that the others have disappeared.
She tells them that the confessions from
the second game
were broadcasted to the entire world
and Shibe's father is in big trouble.
That night, the boys discuss
what to do about the current situation.
A mystery number calls Tenji and asks
if his genius buddy is with him.
The caller displays a photo of Yutori.
Tied up and tells them to meet him in an
abandoned warehouse or she'll be seriously hurt.
Okay. No, no, no, no, no, no.
I say skip that the best way of
going about this situation would be to leave her.
But with the sharks, everyone in our group
seems to be a damn evil piece of crap.
And this game is causing us more trouble
than we could have ever imagined.
If I were the boys, I'd call it a day.
We've just been through
three grueling games together
and had the hardest route
through the game compared to others.
It's not our job to be the local police
and we should probably just go back to school
and hit the books like a normal Japanese teenager.
That being said, though, nearly
100 children have been kidnaped from 2021
to 2022 in the country of Japan.
These crimes have been increasing
at a constant rate, and the police
should be aware that a high school student
has gone completely missing.
We should agree to come to wherever
this mysterious person wants to take us.
Once he gives us the location. Well, then
call the police and tell them where they're at.
It's a win win situation.
We don't have to get our hands dirty
and potentially risk our lives
for the slim chance of success and the police
won't be knocking on our doors
if we end up getting jittery here killed.
Yuichi arrives at the destined location,
only to be confronted by a group of thugs.
This white haired man, Kuroki,
introduces himself as the emcee of the next game,
the weak will game.
Yuichi here isn't allowed to talk or move and
will be forced to go through three rounds of pain
if he can pass them
all. He'll let him and Yutori go free.
However, the battery here
can volunteer to take some of the damage as well.
If she's feeling oh so noble, Kuroki introduces
this massive beefcake
bodybuilder friend and gives the option for Yuichi
to take three hits or four uteri to take one.
She doesn't say anything in time,
and the punishment automatically goes to Yuichi.
The MC introduces the next round called
Fingernail Removal and gives them two options.
Once again, Yutori can have one fingernail removed
or Yuichi can have three
ripped off, and Yuichi steps up to the challenge
and is given the brutal punishment.
The third and final round is the most sadistic
one yet.
The Yutori has the option
of exotically stripping down
and being ogled at by all the guys, or
Yuichi can have his hand gouged out.
Instead, he decides to take the punishment
and has his hand brutally disfigured by the MC.
Yutori begs for forgiveness and apologizes for not
taking any of the pain and patches up his hand.
He forgives the girl and turns over to the M.C.,
offering to play one final game rock,
paper, scissors.
If Kuroki wins,
Yuichi will hand over ¥10 million in cash.
But if he loses, Yuichi gets to cut off
a certain number of fingers, depending
on which hand he threw.
He convinces Kuroki's lackey
to agree with this offer by handing out 1 million
to each person if their leader wins.
Not only that, with his wrapped up hand,
which he can only throw rock or paper
on the count of three they throw down
and the MSI realizes he made a big mistake.
Yuichi throws scissors with his other hand
and wins the game.
Okay, that was a total clutch move
and technically means that he wins him the game.
We're not exactly dealing with morally sound
people here.
These guys are thugs through and through, meaning
they're ready to do
whatever it takes to get at us.
They've already kidnaped our friend here,
so there's likely no way they won't cross the line
when it comes to harming us.
However, the key word is us
and a life or death situation.
There's only one person I care about,
and that's myself.
While we might have convinced his lackeys
to exert later on
and play my game,
there's no telling what the reaction could be.
Once I win through semi alleged cheating
just because it makes sense in a technical way.
It doesn't mean these thugs won't just technically
beat my ass for trying to pull a fast one.
There's nothing stopping us
from leaving this dirty warehouse
and our ragtag group of friends behind.
We will be living stress
free for the rest of our lives
and get out of this shithole
with a few little bumps and bruises.
Furious Kuroki tells his thugs to grab the kid
and teach him a lesson.
That's when the Tomodachi Game Management
bursts inside and restrains all of the thugs.
The managers tell Kuroki
that he's in trouble for impersonating Manabu,
but Yuichi here isn't done with him yet.
He tells the managers to lay off for a second
and says that he must collect his prize and gives
Kuroki an option
for which fingers he wants to cut off.
Suddenly he passes out on the spot and the
managers take him away for emergency medical aid.
They're not going to let their best product die
this easily.
The new girl, Maria, offers the remaining
participants a brand new game to save Shibe.
However, if they lose, they'll be given
¥500 million in debt.
Yuichi wakes up to encourage the others
to keep on going.
All the while,
he chills in the hospital scot free.